شكرا لكابتن رضا السباكه وشكرا موصول
البارد يومك الكرام بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم هنا بالتحديد من الملعب دريم تحت
كوبري الدائري دائري كعبيش هذا الملعب
الاحد الكلاسيكيات اللي موجوده منذ عام
1915 رمضان الحلاق ورضا السباك الاثنين
بقى الحقيقه بين نفسه بعض
[موسيقى]
انا اسمي مصطفى رمضان علي 29 سنه من
محافظه الفيوم والله مشهور بكذا حاجه كان
الاول يا شوالي بعد كده ااا همم تمارست في
تقليد علي محمد علي بقيت علي محمد علي
للغلابه وفي الاخير استقرينا بقى على معلق
الغلابه والله ال- الموضوع بدا من من
الملعب اللي احنا فيه دلوقتي دوت كنا
بنلعب احنا واصحابنا متعودين كل خميس
وجمعه مثلا بنجيء نحجز كلنا طبعا كل واحد
في مجال شغله رضا السباك محمود النجار كده
فبلم بعضنا وبنجيء بتلقائيه انا طبعا صوتي
قريب من الكابتن علي محمد علي شويه
فابتديت بقى ان انا اعلق بس ضيفت يعني
حاجه كوميديه فبقيت ازاي همم من هنا بدات
ال- همم الناس تبص للموضوع بشكل ثاني في
احترافيه في الموضوع وكمان البساطه
والاجور اللي وصلوا للناس هو ده يعني سبب
الانتشار الحمد لله الحمد لله انا برده في
التعليق يعني بقى لي فتره همم علقت في كذا
مكان وشاركت في حاجات رسميه ولكن دائما
احنا ك- كشعب مصر عموما بنحب الفكاهه
الميل للحاجه البسيطه احنا هنا مع اصحابنا
طبعا ما فيش عليك ضغوطات ما فيش سكريبت
مكتوب لك ما فيش اي همم انت محضرها بتطلع
بتلقائيا اللي طلعت من القلب وصلت للقلب
او الفيديو ليا كان انتشر كان في الاستاد
باحضر طاقمت- بالعرض لكن خرجت الى خارج
ارضيه الملعب هنشوفه وتابع امامنا دقيقه
57 من احداث اللقاء الاهلي متسيد الامور
هنا في استاد السلام وواحد لا شيء في هذا
اللقاء روحت البيت عادي جدا صحيت الصبح
على كميه رسائل همم حصل لها لقيت كمان
واحد صعب يكلمني يقول يا عم ده انت قالب
الدنيا لقيت بقى كذا منصه كبيره منزله
الفيديو اللي انا كنت عامله في المدرجات
ومن هنا يمكن ده اول فيديو همم عمل انتشار
وهمم وكان في شهره بالنسبه لي يعني ضبنا
بقى الاستعدادات لكاس العالم النهارده بقى
الورشه كلها جت الصناعيه كلها موجوده
الحقيقه في مواجهه رمضان الحلاق الاسطوره
بقى رمضان الحلاق صاحب الاهداف الكثيره 24
هدف مستر رمضان الحلاق بنفسه طبعا علاء
المنجمي اييي المنتخب في الموضوع انك لما
تلاقي ردود الفعل اللي حواليك لما تلاقي
جنبك مبسوط باللي انت بتعمله فده بيصدر لك
طاقه ايجابيه وبيخليك تستمر ده اول حاجه
والتعليق بالنسبه لي حاجه هوايه مش همم
حاجه حبيبها كمان او كده وناسها ان شاء
الله ونتمنى ان احنا نكون لنا فرصه او
تكون الموضوع بعد كده يبقى مهنيه واا داخل
اعتمد عليه اكيد بحلم اكون معلق رياضي
معتمد او على القنوات الفضائيه بعيدا بقى
عن السوشيال ميديا لان السوشيال ميديا
محدوده اتمنى ان الناس كلها تسمع صوتي
يعبر الفضائيات
على الاقل هنا في الدوري المصري كاس
العالم كان بالنسبه كان بالنسبه لي حلو
على اي منص يعني ولكن الحمد لله يعني قدر
الله وما شاء فعل وده كان حلم كنت انا
اتمناه انا باحب الكابتن علي محمد علي
وهمم بجواره الكابتن عصام الشوالي مجرد ان
انت بس تعلق تلاقي الماتش اللي كان شغال
بقى كان حاجه وتحول لحاجه ثانيه خالص ليه
لان انت بتدي حماس بتصدر للاعيبه دوت
خصوصا لما اللاعب يسمع كده وانه بيعمل
حركه فانت بتعلي صوتك معه فكل اللعيب بدل
ما بيدي 50% لا بيدي 80 و90% من اللي عنده
ادي طبعا الامان ده ارضيه الملعب والحضور
الجماهير اكثر من 12 مشجع النهارده في هذه
البطوله وهدف الاول في اللقاء اخذت لقب
معلق الغلابه ده من الناس مش انا اللي
اتقطع على نفسي ولا انا اللي لقت نفسي كده
همم في معظم التعليقات همم التعليق
الغلابه طبعا وجاي من من قلب الحاجه اللي
احنا بنعملها احنا همم انت فاهم باقول لك
بنعلق رمضان الحلاق في اطار حلقه اليوم
وتصوير اليوم بالملعب المباراه الملعب عمي
فتحي بقى هنا في عبيش تحت كوبري الدائري
اللي بيصطادي واحد بقى من اروع الحلقات
الحقيقه قناه العربيه قلبها اللي بتبص
اخبار واللي بيطنشر اه يعني الايجابيات
حول الوطن العربي ان شاء الله بقى من
خلالكم ومن خلال هذه العدسات صوت ما يوصل
وصوتنا يتسمع للكل باذن الله
[موسيقى]